michel scarbonchi bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
on le disait à l'instant les danois on
sait la situation est très compliquée en
afghanistan et pourtant les danois ont
décidé de renvoyer leurs réfugiés en
afghanistan comment il explique c'est
assez incompréhensible
il y à 907 afghans qui ont été rapatriés
de kaboul à copenhague à caen kaboul est
tombé par les danois
c'est 907 afghans ont été mis dans des
camps le demandeur d'asile seulement 250
d'entre eux ont obtenu une carte de
séjour donc ça veut dire seulement un
quart les autres sont toujours quasiment
internés et sens ensemble possibilités
d'évolution de leur situation est
maintenant en plus le danemark a décidé
de les rapatrier
à kaboul quand on sait que l'afghanistan
est menacée de famine renvoyer ces gens
d'abord c'est les mettre en danger en
termes de sécurité puisqu'ils sont
considérés comme des auxiliaires de
l'armée
danoise et donc des occidentaux pendant
la guerre contre les talibans donc ce
sont des gens dans la vie est en danger
c'est assez absurde mais ça démontre
bien l'absence de politique européenne
rue voilà c'est ça n'y a pas d'unité
finalement se sentit son cher pays
adopte ses propres règles la france elle
même avait avait adopté un processus
kaboul intitulé comme ceux comme celui
qui permettait une protection
internationale pour tout l'est pour tous
les afghans ayant été confrontées à de
la violence aveugle ça a été suspendu
par le para par la commission droit
d'asile en france en 2020 confirmée par
le conseil d'état en 2021 et donc nous
mêmes nous sommes confrontés à ça est-ce
qu'on va rapatrier des gens etc sait on
est dans la situation les les
auxiliaires afghans sont en train de
devenir les nouveaux requis des nouveaux
harkis c'est à dire des gens qui nous
ont aidés qui ont collaboré avec nous
comme traducteurs etc etc et qui
maintenant sont sont abandonnés alors
qu'on les a rapatriés avec nous on les a
ramené ce qui était fort bien ce qui
était correct et maintenant on les
abandonne et en plus on veut les qu'il
reparte ça prouve à quel point il n'y a
pas de politique européenne des réfugiés
et à ce titre je pense que prochainement
le président macron comme président de
l'union européenne va annoncer la
création d'une agence européenne des
réfugiés c'est à dire on va centraliser
tous les réfugiés quelles que soient
leurs origines qui se présentent aux
frontières de l'union européenne seront
centralisées
par cette agence est ensuite s'ils sont
acceptés comme demandeurs d'asile ou
comme réfugiés ils sont dispatchés dans
les différents pays alors qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez on se présente par exemple au
danemark le danemark vous refuse mais
vous allez en belgique vous allez vous
allez en suède vous allez en france et
vous vous baladez comme ça on crée on
crée du nomadisme des réfugiés
politiques en europe
parce que nous n'avons pas une règle
constante pour tous les états par
exemple italie qui est le pays qui
accueille le plus de réfugiés 1 84 4 11%
des réfugiés afghans ont été acceptés en
italie
suivant les règles italienne en là la
france par exemple à côté c'est 13%
d'accord et vous avez actuellement dans
le monde vous avez à peu près deux
millions six cent mille réfugiés afghans
dont la grande majorité 85% et est
concentré sur les pays voisins c'est à
dire pakistan iran menace pour cent en
europe en tout cas la situation sur
place on l'a vu est catastrophique on
peut le dire d'autant des milliers de
personnes ont défilé
hier dans les rues d'afghanistan pour
protéger pour protester contre une
décision américaine qui est celle de
saisir près de 3 milliards 5 de dollars
dans les réserves de la banque centrale
afghane expliquez-nous tout à fait pour
quelles raisons joe biden a pris cette
décision parce qu'il veut faire pression
sur les talibans donc ils utilisent
l'argent là la pression de l'argent dans
un pays au bord de la famine
exsangue par la guerre pour pour les
obliger à assouplir leurs positions
notamment sur leur comportement à
l'égard des femmes sur la scolarisation
des jeunes filles qui sont des problèmes
qu'ils sont toujours pas réglés même si
les talibans ont pris les engagements
concernant la scolarisation des défis
dans leur pays mais pour l'instant bon
voilà je pense que ils utilisent cette
arme mais bon au bout au bout de cette
arme il ya la famine la famille de
populations civiles
ouais parce qu'effectivement je disais
de 3 milliards 5,6 et 7 milliards parce
que dans le même temps on a vu les
nations unies le royaume uni aussi qui a
fait là un grand sommet pour débloquer
plus de 4 milliards il semble justement
pour venir en aide à ces populations
pourquoi c'est pas possible aujourd'hui
de débloquer l'argent des afghans
justement pour leur redistribuer pour
lutter contre cette famille ça serait
logique qu'on débloque cet argent je
pense que l'europe va faire pression
pour arriver à cette solution et en
faisant de cette politique d' affamer
nous sommes en train de faire le jeu de
la chine et de la russie
puisque la chine et la russie sont
présentes un chacun sont présents à
kaboul et eux continuent à discuter avec
les avec les talibans
pensant qu'ils vont évoluer alors
l'europe et les occidentaux ont mis des
conditions forte c'est à dire quant à la
nomination d'un gouvernement inclusif
c'est à dire permettant à toutes les
parties d'être présents permettant à des
hommes et des femmes au gouvernement ce
qui n'était pas le cas jusqu'à présent
et donc
il ya une bataille morale et politique
et sociétale qui est en train de se
jouer dans cette affaire parce que les
talibans ils ont menacé de reconsidérer
leur politique vis-à-vis des etats-unis
mais quel type de mesure ils pourraient
prendre aujourd'hui pas grand choix
aussi qu aucune mesure il ya plus
personne n'ya pas d'ambassade il n'y a
rien nous avons tous tout abandonner à
kaboul avec la chute de kaboul quand
nous sommes partis dans cette danse est
dans cette fuite
voulue par monsieur train et réalisé par
monsieur byden
républicains démocrates
et nous avons donné un très mauvais
signal d'ailleurs
au monde entier et
et l'affairé craignait n'est pas n'est
pas étrangère à ce qui se passe
là férus craignait n'est pas étrangère
aux conséquences de kaboul on y
reviendra en vous car merci pour votre
éclairage ce matin sur notre antenne
michel scarbonchi député européen merci